[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん孫の重視ってますでしょうかまあすごい多分女じゃあ
ねってこれだと思うんですけどもラグも引っかけて公演だけで銃ができるんですよこう
やって横で打つといったっはぁはぁっ
うさあ今のちょっと腑に落ちなんで自分の方に飛んできたんでもいません
bar 普通に出た出た叛逆低下では同じがあるんですけどもこんなチンケな保護中だ
東北は早いです
27歳でもというわけで今日はなりませって木でできてるんですよってことは木の材料
を使えばもっと大きくてかっこいいもう何がいいこういうこういうイメージのは無事が
作りたいと思ったんで今日は何か色々も来ないよ買ってきましたこれだけのも片山多分
は米中のめちゃくちゃ刑罰を作れると思うんですよそれで今日の動画はなんだかして
政界一かっこいい
いうバンコム子をつくってみたいと思いますあのそんなにモノをつくったことないです
けど多分なベージュはこれでいいんで
これっぽい肝心のやってをこのボックスでで作ればきっと目指した過去やってないと
思うんでこれを参考にちょっと作っていきたいと思います出会い5組ほどいデザイナー
のしょぼいです
木材第二枚カットしやすいように細身にしております木材中に後同じ長さのがなかった
ですって人です
木材ショーぼくはも多分使い勝手が良いと思います木材商を出しに行こう
違いがよくわかんなかったけどちょっと色が濃いですぼく大黒4枚以前のでカットに
使いやすいかと思いましたみたいなと格好に使い方で面へデーブ
もし7ヒロ過去に使いそうですハンマーかっこいいので黒にしましたのー位ファイナル
ファンタジーたの主人公を含むが使ってゆう丸ベルトような繁盛していたので買って
しまいました
ファイナルマッチして3のリメイク発売おめでとう
ございます以上ですというわけで早速作っていきたいと思いますそれを行うも巨大化
するだけで結構行ってると思ってるんですよね
だけでまずは元となるかもないか元の通信部分作っていきたいとおもいます
y 動くこんなのやったことないようできるかなできる子
できるかできるかな
pr
pl
よっしゃん
いい数ではないだろうか普通部分になりますねこれがこういうイメージですどんどん
やっていきましょう
恨む呪詛頑張ります
うんいい敵がよし
次がなんとなく2枚の格好いい気がするんでなぜこんなイメージ図を作っていきたいと
おもいます
なんか凄い事するように見えたものを区切ってるだけですからねだるまもできそうな
ことをど英語で言ってるだけですよ
[拍手]
うんいい感じだ香苗中ぽくなってきましたもう一人です
やはり黒こうしたいんですよねや難しいけど多分でいそうなんだよなぁしてっています
練習とりあえず先行ですもう一歩ついてもちゃんとを挟まれます
かなりいい感じになってきたけどもう酷いですね全然中詳しくないんですけど中の先端
に中こういうし花粉がついてになりませんそれしましょう
っぽいこれなんかつけて良かったのか不安になってきましたよ大丈夫かなぁん
第乗車さあここからですどうしましょう
ん身近な
悪くないで
やばいやばい
a
[音楽]
いやだ落としたけどいやもうかなりぽいと思いますけどねこれもう
以上こんな感じになっておりますでカーただ忘れて欲しくないのがまだは米が飛びませ
んただそのギミック字型機は割り箸があればできると思うんでそれ馬から作っていき
たいと思いますというで普通にも利用して作っています
[音楽]
i find したですかああ
ああああああ
多分これ移動してっ
結局最後はホームダイブです
だが結局人がいっぱいだんけど結局はホームなんすよたどり着くのはノー柔軟で
なるべくこれないようにホームでぐるぐる巻きにしましょう
[音楽]
かなり安定感を増してきましたもう沿いです元に完成しますもう今最後の輪ゴムが発射
できる土台をつくっております
不安定だでもこういうことなんだろう
いける
ます bar 声時計出るしかないんですよ
[音楽]
というわけで常に感染しました分かりませんが僕ひょんなベルト
世界一かっこいいそして世界一で開運の気がする
ばゴム銃の完成ですということで細かい部分見ていきましょう
それでちょっと自立しないんで声を着方じゃないとちょっと受けませんごめんなさい
いや普通にもただの俺好みの中になっちゃいましたよこれ
とってがこんな感じでしただけちょっとプロット前になるんですけどもソリーが予報
ワゴン後木材後釘でできていきますはい
な感じですここに大量の舞場所があるでいつでもご飯が食べられますこの引っかかっ
てるはことが無駄にかっこいいと思うんですよねここでは今後引っかかっけってこれを
聴いてると
国家のバーンててるっていう入ってゆけちょっと言うじゃないか話したんですけどもう
こんなけ見た目がかっこいいんですけども
結局威力はこれが変わりません
先生が皆さん覚えておいてください大事なのは威力ではなく良いためですと指で早速
実戦で使ってみると思います
月経
[音楽]
セット完了だな
hey hey
rarejob to do
でわっ
ヒュー do